(audience applauding and cheering)
- Wow!
Woo!
- [Kelly] Woo! How are you?
- [Michael] Woo!
- Woo! We're just gonna keep doing it.
- Lets just do it. Lets do it.
- [Kelly] No seriously, oh my gosh
your eyes in person are
just like next level.
- Oh, thank you, thank you.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- [Michael] I'm glad they work.
- Way to go, God. Yeah, way to go.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
- So you have been married
for 7 years, right?
- Yes.
- Okay, do you have any advice
for Max and Julianne
up there? Just saying.
- First of all, congratulations.
(audience applauding and cheering)
What an incredible story.
And, you know, it's funny because
your story reminds me of a Sade song.
- [Kelly] Woo.
- [Michael] Love is stronger than pride.
Your story gives so many people
hope to kind of put pride aside,
compromise, go with love.
You understand what I'm saying?
- [Kelly] Man a man that loves Sade.
Lets say stuff about that.
(audience applauding)
That's hot.
(laughing)
I love Sade.
So, what was your first
date like with your wife?
- It was more like a take over.
(everyone laughing)
- I love her already.
- Exactly. Every woman says that
when I tell this story.
So, my wife had
she basically told me that
this other guy was not her boyfriend.
- Oh.
- So I asked her about it and
she said no he's not my type.
He's not my boyfriend.
He's never been my
boyfriend. You're my type.
- Oh, she went right in there.
- That was the first time
she ever said that to me.
And I was like oh okay.
- Yeah.
- So, I think I called her the day after
and was like okay, so, can we go
out on like, Tuesday night.
She's like no.
Okay?
- [Kelly] Oh, just like
no reason. Just like nah.
- She's like no, I'm working.
I was like oh, okay, great.
Well, I get it. How about like Thursday?
No, I'm working.
(laughing)
She was like this.
I have Monday off, that's
the day we'll go out.
And I was like this, okay?
(laughing)
I didn't know what to say.
I was like ha ha ha. Okay.
- It's kind of hot. She's bold.
Yeah.
- I think in hindsight.
- I think it worked.
- In hindsight, it worked.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(laughing)
- In hindsight, it worked.
I think in the moment I was
just like kind of taken aback.
- Like, is she crazy? Yeah.
- And I think I was drawn to that.
(laughing)
- That says more about you.
- I was definitely drawn to that.
And then the first date, we actually
linked up during the day because
she was like I'm gonna work tonight
but lets do something during the day.
I was like a day date? Sexy. Right.
(laughing)
One of the hottest things I've ever done.
(audience laughing)
So we went to this
Vietnamese restaurant and
we ate and then I didn't want it to end.
So, I was like, what else could I do?
What else could I do?
And she was sitting there and we were
talking and we were
talking and she says to me
um can we get the first
kiss out of the way?
- Yeah.
- [Michael] She was like I am
feeling you and I'm telling
you right now if it's
bad or if it's wack I
just want to go home
and never see you again.
(everyone laughing)
We're still together. So it was good.
- So good job.
(audience applauding)
- It was good. I put it on her.
- Good job, good job.
So wait, my question though is like
now she's your wife and after 7 years
like this is the thing I don't get and
I could never date an actor because
I ain't seeing my man
with some other chick
up on a film being like
nah it's just for work.
(audience laughing)
- It's just for work.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that is a
different level of comfortable.
- First of all, I am an
artist and it is acting.
- Sure.
- It is always one hundred percent acting.
She just never got weird
about it, you know.
- She's comfortable. She's confident.
- She's always said because her
girlfriends, to this day, even
to this day, will see me make out
with Cobie on Stumptown and be
- [Kelly] Yeah.
like, you know, I don't how you do it.
I don't know how you do it and
she tells them the same thing every time.
Look, he's never given
me a reason to doubt.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
(audience cheering)
Absolutely, absolutely.
(audience applauding)
That's cool. That's a
confident relationship, too.
I love that.
So, our kids are almost the same age.
They're similar ages.
Are your kids into performing like you?
- Sadly, yes.
- Okay. Me too.
- It is something that you probably
I don't know about you.
I try to prevent it at all costs
and there's just no way around it.
My daughter, who's three, she
(audience awes)
- [Kelly] Oh my God with the one eye.
- She had her first Winterfest celebration
at her little pre-school.
- Oh my God, those are the best.
- Exactly, exactly.
I didn't know about this.
This is a gem nobody told me about.
So, they bring out all the kids and
my daughter was dead center and
she comes out and she's looking.
You can tell she's looking
- [Kelly] Oh.
- For her mom and me and I'm like
and so I'm holding the camera and she's
not looking over, she's not looking over.
So I start calling her nickname.
Which is boo boo.
(laughing)
Boo boo!
- [Kelly] You're that dad.
(audience awes)
- And then she gives us
like a Miss America wave.
(everyone laughs)
- Hey Dad!
- And I was just like this.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(muttering)
- Oh my God.
- Are you experiencing you said
three years old, right?
- [Michael] Three, yeah.
- She's three. So, I
mean, three-nager, right?
Has that been real?
- Absolutely three-nager.
- Three-nager.
- And this is a new term to me.
I didn't know this.
- Oh, welcome.
- [Michael] It's absolutely true. Yeah.
- We have a three year old.
- [Michael] Boy or girl?
- Boy.
- [Michael] Okay.
- And he just destroys everything.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like a psychopath.
Just like woo woo!
- Yeah.
- Just like, just everywhere.
- That changes.
- Yeah.
- It changes.
- Hopefully.
(laughing)
- But she like, we couldn't figure
out who she was like for years.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Because she's not exactly like my wife.
She's not exactly like me.
She has, you know, and
I hate this term now
because they only use it for girls.
People call her sassy, right?
And I'm like well why we
only use that term for girls?
- Oh, I use that for many guy friends.
(audience laughing)
- I've never heard of that.
That being said it was one of those
things where she um.
I realized that she's just like my aunt.
My aunt Chantice in D.C.
She is sweet as pie
but she will cut you.
(audience laughing)
if you cross her
- [Kelly] I like her.
- Or you hurt someone in
her family she will cut you.
She came to set and we were doing a scene
on something where I was like
a car was being stolen and the
woman's who car I tried to chase
after the car and the woman who's
car was stolen started hitting me
when I tried to help her off the ground
and my wife had explained to her this
whole story about how dad was a superhero
and this was the princess and the
thieves stole the princess's carriage
(audience laughing)
and so, exactly, she's
creative in this way.
After the take I get
up and my daughter says
daddy, why did the princess hit you?
And I said, um, uh and I looked up
and my wife was like go with it.
(laughing)
I was like because uh I'm
trying to get her car back.
And she was like where's the princess?
And I was like she's right here.
- Oh, she's gonna cut the princess.
- She went up to the
princess, the actress,
and says you don't hit my daddy.
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
(laughing)
- He's a superhero and then she
crawls in my arms and hugged me
and I woo.
- Like what do you want
a unicorn I'll find one.